Daniel ate four slices of cake
Gabriella ate four slices if there were
two slices remaining what fraction of
the cake was eaten let's think about
this Daniel ate four slices so I'll just
do a circle for a slice we're gonna do a
triangle so one slice - slice three
slices and four slices that's what
Daniel eight Gabriela ate four slices
one two three and four two slices remain
uneaten so one and two what fraction of
the cake was eaten
so the fraction eaten is going to be the
number eaten number of the pieces eaten
of the slices eaten over the total
slices the total slices that is the
fraction of the cake that is eaten
fraction of the cake is eaten is this
right over here number eaten over total
slices so what is the number eaten the
number eaten is these four plus these
four right over here so total of eight
slices have been eaten so that is eight
slices and then how many total slices
are there to this cake and I will do
that in well let me see I will do that
in yellow the total slices are ten there
are 10 total slices you can count them
there the eight eaten plus the two left
over so there are 10 total slices so
what fraction of the cake was eaten 8/10
and if we want to put that in lowest
terms both of these are divisible by 2
so we can divide both the numerator and
the denominator by 2 and we get 4 over 5
four-fifths of the cake was eaten